hi there Steve Kaufman I'm going to
today I didn't get any Korean Don
zero-day a t10 Korean study except for
the little bit that I listened to on my
way to where I spent the rest of my day
today I am a bit of a rebel always have
been I have a good friend a Chinese
fellow who is who goes against the flow
of the Chinese community immigrant
community here we spend a lot of their
time complaining about how things should
be better for them my friend mr. Huang
says and he has a group he calls the
Alliance for the support of Canadian
values and his point of view is people
come here to Canada they should be
thankful that there in Canada they
should have support the greater common
interest of all Canadians rather than
always trying to get a better deal for
their Chinese community and he runs into
a lot of trouble and and to a large
extent the Chinese community the recent
immigrants are very much influenced by
the Chinese consulate and Chinese
government policy and he's not afraid to
go against that so whenever he organizes
an event and there's generally you know
the ethnic press the Chinese media is
there I'll generally go there to support
him and today the subject was the change
in Canadian legislation governing invest
investor immigrants where there was a
system where as long as you lent the
Canadian government $800,000 you could
get a passport which was just abused
often the money was just bored from a
bank here it wasn't invested in a
significant employment creating
enterprise it was just a fast track for
people with money which a lot of people
thought was unfair and finally the
government despite their inclination the
won a win votes any way they can and
operating on the squeaky wheel gets more
attention you know gets more oil
principle have have maintained this
program for 20 odd years even though
it's proven to be ineffective I took a
friend of mine who's an expert on
immigration who is 82 and
recently had a knee replacement so I had
to pick him up and he's struggling to
get into my car it's raining we drive
out to Richmond we have a Chinese meal
with the group and then we go to this
meeting so I'm gonna if it works as M
had trouble uploading my videos if it
works you're gonna see no Korean today
but you're gonna see some excerpts from
both the television interview that I did
and my some of my remarks to the group
what's that got to do with 81 day
challenge not much except to say that
you know we're winding down it is
pressure to say for 90 days I've got to
put in two three hours a day into
language learning I'm not gonna get to
three hours in tomorrow either because
I'm going to play golf with my wife I'm
gonna try and get some in I think as I
said before I'm over the hump I've
developed a base in Korean a base of
knowledge base of familiarity a base of
content that can keep me going for quite
a while but I'm gonna try and maintain
you know my least an hour to a day but
I'm just being ambushed by the
Ukrainians situation by these Chinese
people by my wife playing golf it's just
not possible when I was a full-time
student of Chinese I could just devote
every day to learning Chinese I just
can't do that anymore if you're young
out there you don't have any excuses but
I have other obligations so hopefully
you'll be able to look at these clips if
you speak Chinese you'll understand if
you don't I'll tell you roughly what
it's about it's this whole immigrant you
know investor immigrant thing and my
perspective is that all immigrants
should be treated the same
there should be no special treatment for
these wealthy immigrants unless they
make a significant investment like build
a factory like several millions of
dollars like a major employment creation
opportunity not just to come in and buy
a passport and the best immigrants are
the ones that come here and work and
contribute and integrate in our society
not the ones that buy a passport and
then move back to Beijing and come here
when they're also they can take
advantage of the health system
and unfortunately that's what's happened
in a lot of cases now the you know
immigrant consultants immigrant law
immigration lawyers and of course the
real estate agents they love having
these people come but as was pointed out
in the meeting it means that a lot of
young people can't buy homes in
Vancouver because they're too expensive
prices are driven up by these wealthy
people not exclusively but it's it's a
contributing factor but fundamentally
it's just not fair line up with everyone
else if you have the qualifications to
get in fine and when she come in we
would like you to stay here and
contribute and so those were some of the
things that we talked about I also
mentioned the fact that contrary to
prevailing you know orthodoxy in Canada
that we are this multicultural society
as opposed to the American melting pot
in fact that's not true at all Canada is
just as much of a melting pot generally
speaking in the past people just blend
in by the third generation they're
probably not married to someone of the
same ethnic origin and really that's the
only way you can run a country you can't
have a country that consists of and then
you got the Chinese over here and the
Punjabis over there and the Iranians
over here and the Greeks over here and
the Italians first generation they love
that but by the second and third
generation it tends to to get watered
down and the politicians support all of
this multicultural stuff because they
think it's a way of kinda a convenient
way to gather in votes from this ethnic
group and that's that ethnic group but
it's not really in the interest of the
country in my view so those are the some
of the issues that were discussed but
I'm not gonna make subtitles and
hopefully the whole video gets uploaded
by for now
what would I change you may want the
contacted Omar Khayyam college I do it
so you candy
Jonathan he founded a additionally Yadav
a common coming in there Conchita teach
you in the pipeline we are the G [ __ ]
occur when he to hold it when ya watchin
the medium giver or pay poor news a
janitor
take each other
the male human connection diode never
paralyzed me give it in even don't wanna
eat honey and see one day grunting Oh
chichi shoe for the day of money you
know bundle my conductivity future
bromine Archer
it's a Jonathan you were foolish really
member tdye palliative adequacy shock
today you may turn her shoes in the body
connection spicy tomato farm yeah panda
hiccup oh [ __ ] in the deep so indeed I
die tautology mother Chaucer's easier
way to be jumpin either yeah yeah don't
worry
Maine Warden Jonathan Georgia neva
Georgia did you enter booyah hey David
O'Russell for double yeah there is a
center you die ja Matta Biggio chop you
ever ever even younger take attach it to
your shoulder well what channel dollars
for play the Billy team a what I got
give it to you my one true photographer
so you're done with us even the Pope out
there is [ __ ] already waited you mean
you can even Arthur - children yeah we
came from majority of which are Roman
Tom awakened into the to hold another
come up with a linear kernel being why
don't you work on them so I go eat our
Sunday eating Jordi Hurtado so ETA Omega
magic even from yeah maybe